killer instinct is getting a brand new  contender the fighter was teased at the  very end of the recently released Kim  Woo trailer the blink and you'll miss it  reveals shows off the scene from the  hailer verse and suggests that halos  arbiter will be joining the killer  instinct roster in season 3 the Kim will  reveal came during pack south where  developer I'm galaxy also announced a  heap of new info on killer instincts  upcoming season season 3 will include a  whole lot of character balance  adjustments which you can read about in  detail in our story on gamespot let me  know what killer instinct fighter you  favor and if you're keen to try out  halos arbiter for all the latest killer  instinct news as well as everything else  that matters in gaming we'll keep you  updated